oh my god
Minneapolis sir [ __ ] whatever you have
it sir I'm sorry I'm not allowed to give
you any alcohol says who the doctor that
carried you on to the planned I hate to
see me cuz you're my brother and you
break in mom and dad's on us truth is I
don't need to be here I'm not like these
other people while the same in here we
got to look out for one another
[Music]
I've never seen this degree of
degradation in someone so young if you
were to start using again it's more than
likely that you were going to cardiac
arrest and immediately
let's take a walk are you doing some
days I feel okay others I just want to
crawl up and I don't call and I tell you
that as soon as you realize that there
is no choice there's a choice
not an addict I'm not an addict you
don't have the balls to face it that's
what I think so you do have life left in
you you can win this things can't yeah
you can
you don't have to do this alone
you know we could get thrown out for
doing this a second of freedom is worth
more than a lifetime of bondage
I'm just scared I'm leaving I know that
I'm not better I try
you got two choices you can let it kill
you
you can let it go and move on
make peace for yourself
you're worthwhile human being James
we've got a lot to give people
[Music]
goddamn I'm about her gorilla [ __ ] the
treehouse I'm glad I could be a service
you